good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-1505
object class
euclid
special containment procedures
diplomatic relations with scp-1505 have
been established under the terms of the
sarai treaty a permanent researcher is
to be stationed on scp-5005 at all times
whose presence can only be allowed or
rescinded by the agreement of the
project lead and two foundation
psychologists other foundation personnel
are permitted conditional research
access to scp-1505
with the approval of their supervisor
access is gained via a scranton mayor
beer arc from site q46
located in the adzane universe on the
far side of the western cluster contact
your extra universal contact form more
information
personnel are reminded that a prolonged
stay in scp-505
may be severely emotionally taxing and
are encouraged to consider their own
mental health before entering
description
scp-5054 is a human settlement located
3449 waylands to the multiversal east of
the central reality compass and 87
waylands beyond where matter is
ordinarily capable of permanently
existing consequently it is the most
remote settlement created by a sentient
creature and the most remote matter in
existence
scp-505 is constructed on an expanse of
an earth-like substance which acts as
fertile soil the extent of this expanse
is unknown as it is impossible to engage
in long-term exploration beyond the
limits of
scp-5805-1's light range
scp-5805-1 is a large biomechanical
lantern suspended over scp-5805
scp-5051's light possesses a degree of
reality stabilization far in excess of
any other known examples allowing for
the permanent existence of matter within
its light range however
scp-5051's capacity as a light source is
limited and temperamental due to its
size and distance from scp-505
its lux illumination is relatively low
in the settlement it is frequently
described as being similar to the light
of a full moon on earth
scp-5051 is suspended above scp-505 by a
large protruding tendril which emerges
from the expanse and forms an arc above
scp-1505 the tendril is believed to be
constructed from an artificially
hardened and strengthened form of the
expanse substance
the composition of the expanse substance
is unknown various scholars have
proposed a link to sriskin holocron
which possesses a similarly unusual
molecular structure however the
archaeological record of shrisca is very
limited and no currently known sriskin
technologies could create something on
the scale of the expanse substance the
resonance of scp-1505 refer to the
substance as mahi-lom a word which has
no known connection to any of the
cultures on scp-1505 and is of unknown
providence further investigation is
required
the following is an assessment of other
anecdotal evidence and theories
concerning scp-505 surroundings by dr
hamish franklin project lead on scp-5005
although the historical documentation
surrounding scp-505's founding and
history is relatively extensive
any scientific understanding of the
town's surroundings or its light source
remains beyond our capabilities it's
clear from the mechanical elements
within scp-5805-1
that it is a synthetic creation of an
unknown civilization
but there is nothing we can find that is
remotely similar to it there are some
some similarities to schrisken
technologies within the substance of the
expanse but that kind of molecular
structure has its forebears in any
number of universes in that cluster and
beyond adzain
parkrit
carrick what all of them lack is
anything even slightly as advanced as a
cp5051
which can create almost earth-like
conditions
in the midst of unreality
any number of theories have come forward
a research experiment of the old empire
a neo-austrian birthing ground an
adzanian horse culling center
one biologist even thought it could be
the remains of a hawker pioneers
anglerfish
these ideas are innovative but remain at
best only mere speculation
not even the populace can provide any
clues whatever ancient people made it
must be long dead now we cannot send a
foundation personnel beyond the city
limits of course far too dangerous and
the most anecdotes from the town's
explorers simply speak of more and more
dark and that gradual unsettling feeling
that they've been away from the light
for too long would-be pioneers have
either been driven back swiftly or have
disappeared
only one anecdote has been preserved
that holds any interest for us roughly a
century ago a particularly daring or
drunken poet decided to pick a direction
and head that way as long as possible he
was just about suicidal enough to stick
with it longer than most others but not
so determined that he didn't eventually
turn back
out there many miles away he happened to
glance at his hand and saw it begin to
unravel
in panic he stared across the landscape
and saw a brief glint on the horizon
thinking it was home he headed fast
towards it but after crossing a
prominent ridge he found that he'd been
going in the wrong direction entirely
before him lay a glassy orb of immense
proportions the color of milk embedded
into the earth and a faint light shone
beneath its surface by some miracle he
managed to get home
there wasn't much of him left and it
didn't take long before he expired but
his half-mad lunatic story he screamed
out has stuck in the town's law for most
of the townsfolk it remains a cautionary
tale for those who might consider
stepping beyond the light's edge
the following are a series of
introductory essays on aspects of
scp-505 by academics and foundation
personnel in these saul and orchard
universes who have studied the anomaly
these have been supplemented by
foundation logs that provide examples of
the phenomena discussed
number one history by dr johannes cobalt
level 3 foundation historian
scp-5005 was founded by jean antoine
delacroix a noted poet from the orchard
universe and former drago man in the
kaivan republic delacroix discovered
scp-505's location following the
dissolution of his relationship with the
strathclyde painter emily wolf leaving
him in a state of extreme depression he
attempted suicide via arc blinking
launching himself in a random direction
in the hope of expiring in the
non-matter surrounding the multiverse
instead delacroix arrived close to
scp-5051
deeply curious about the location he
blinked himself home to embark on a
series of explorations of the site he
founded scp-5005 in 2107 and gave it the
name lamplight which remains its common
name to this day delacroix's stated
intention in founding the settlement was
to create a place that could provide a
home to the damned the dispossessed the
refugees and the lost
however the initial inhabitants were
almost entirely artists writers and
intellectuals from the orchard universe
quickly ending delacroix's utopian hopes
for the town he again fell into
depression and disappeared in 2110.
subsequent immigration to scp-1505 has
followed a similar pattern with the
majority of the town's population
belonging to academic or artistic
professions most other inhabitants are
the survivors or descendants of two
major influxes of refugees who took up
residence in scp-505
a group of survivors of the neon london
in 2396
and the remnants of the tribes of the
many steps in 2419.
the nature of time in scp-1505's
non-matter surroundings means that human
aging varies greatly from person to
person consequently while some visitors
have undergone the span of a full human
life in a single 24-hour cycle others
have shown no visible signs of aging
across many centuries this allows for an
impressive range of sources for
scp-505's history an example of this can
be found in the following interview with
sergey osmanoglu the owner of the
dragoman tavern who emigrated to
scp-1505 in 2109
interviewer junior researcher sophia
ramirez location drago man tavern date
2911
2524 begin log ramirez is sitting in the
main room of the tavern at a table by a
window she has just switched on a
recording device and placed it in front
of her a tall burly man with a thick
beard osmanoglu is sitting opposite her
snow can be seen passing by the window
there is a lit fireplace behind
osmaniglu
thank you for agreeing to this interview
sergey
it's not a problem
i've got time and you pay the rent
promptly
i
oh okay
when did you first arrive in lamplight
2009 i think
it was a long time ago
what was the town like then
small
cold fewer buildings fewer lamps
less snow
yes i wanted to ask about that how is
there snow but it was better back then
delacroix was there
people said he founded the place
but they couldn't understand how they
could think that
what do you mean he didn't have the
energy
no spark
he'd spend all his time staring out
there into the dark
this place wasn't meant for us
and you can't know that for sure the
soil here is so perfectly suited to
supporting human life you don't make a
place for people with that thing
suspended over it you'll build a sun or
stars not a pallid half moon there are
no places for humans this far
other civilizations got close
sriska park red they weren't humans
wrong cluster
and if they did make this place and they
doubt it
then they are long gone now
nothing but their dust and their lamp
left over
so
what did delacroix do
he had a girl
and it went sour
so he came here to start something new
something great
but the only ones entranced by his mad
designs were the same old crowd of poets
all talking about the great utopia they
built here
another society of true freedom to
escape the horrors of the dozen others
they made
but they didn't want to do the hard
graft or come down from their bohemian
bubbles
so it was all pork shooting [ __ ] in
taverns like this one
i'm the only one left now
delacroix though
he was smart
he could see this
first time i saw him he'd been here two
years
and the absinthe had reached his eyes
he saw that all he done was make more
meaningless ego
but i think
i think part of him loved the misery he
felt he wrote his best poems here
everyone says so about the dark is a
mirror around
about other stuff
you've read it
not yet no
it's hard to get copy and soul you're
the next universe over should be easy
on orchard you can find him anywhere
not so much here
people don't like to remember him here
and why not
because he talked the truth the poets
don't want to hear
or because we all know what happened to
him
oh there are those that say he went back
to orchard
but any true lamplighter knows he
stepped into the night
[Applause]
the knight does not give such easy
answers he used to
say
i would just pet him on the shoulder and
tell him it was okay and
he was not the well man sofia
he wanted to destroy himself
[Music]
yeah we don't like to talk about that
suicide right
no
more than that
i don't think he wanted to die
to end
he wanted to annihilate the idea
of himself
he'd come here and order absent over and
over and over again
staring at
the snow
and trying to make out shapes
then one day
he was gone
i
i see
you should go home sophia
go back to your soul
to your foundation
this is not a place for well people
then why are you here
someone has to care for the sick
[Music]
i saw you watching customer
from your window
i don't
what a know
coat
you saw him
didn't you
walking down the cobbled streets he was
a playwright from davistown smoked those
pipes wrote with trembling hands under
the gaslamps
put the fire on and keep it warm but he
hasn't been back for days
just
walked into the smog on the foot beating
at heart di march
withdrawing the other is a faintly
whistling silhouette
you saw him
and said nothing
i think you are like him
in a way
that'll be all for now
end log
number two
structure in society by dr harry grant
lecturer in eastern multiverse studies
at king's college london
scp-5005
is properly a series of five small
districts loosely gathered around a
central plaza the wolf square three of
these districts were created by the
various artistic groups present in
scp-5005
across the centuries and consequently
reflecting their sensibilities the other
two were founded by refugee groups
the districts are
the kaivan or victorian district was the
original core of the city founded by
jean antoine delacroix in 2109 the
architectural style is reminiscent of
the light nipirian style roughly
analogous to a mixture of victorian and
imperial russian architecture in the
saul universe but with some oddities
such as a strict adherence to cowled
streets and the regular placement of gas
lamps the ardent romanticism of the
city's founders has led to the structure
of this district being deliberately
disorganized it has frequently been
admired for its many communal meeting
places and frequent public concerts
the ethereum district was created during
the cyberpunk revival of the 2350s a
response to the horrors of the burnt
apple war that caused severe destruction
to the orchard universe's earth the
cyberpunk revival was marked by deep
cynicism and disillusionment with
contemporary politics reflected in an
architectural style deliberately modeled
on post-industrial decay and
internet-based subcultures the district
is thus highly architecturally varied
and was renowned for its anarchist
politics which were credited with an
urban and social regeneration across the
settlement
the giano district was created by a
group of saul universe artists who in
response to the nambian crisis of the
2390s wanted a radical return to the
pre-modernity as a response to the evils
of the present the group vehemently
opposed to all realism and art created
the district as a way to return to a
world of starker light constructing
buildings exclusively in gothic or
romanesque church architecture and with
an emphasis on stained glass's light
refracting properties the early days of
this district were marked by an ascetic
medieval morality almost entirely absent
today the modern neighborhood is chiefly
known for its biannual passion plays and
wide range of communal and charitable
activities
the neoclassical district was founded by
refugees fleeing the neon london in the
early 25th century characterized by 18th
century british architecture but
augmented by a large number of green
spaces flowing curves and a stated
desire to create utopia this district
was rigidly and rigorously planned as an
ideal community of elites although this
project has been long abandoned the
neighborhood has become a focal point
for a great number of literary circles
with young artists frequently attending
its salons and literary festivals and
many patrons settling in the district
the nomad district was created by the
surviving tribes of the many steps most
of the structures here are yurts and
other nomadic tents utilized by the
salome universe's inner asia analog but
at the center of the district is a
manichaean temple of particular
architectural significance even beyond
scp-1505 the district is frequently
engaged in housing refugees from across
the multiverse a cause that many of
scp-505's residents involved themselves
in
despite many historical differences
conflicts and disagreements between
these districts are now uncommon with
the populace as a whole freely mingling
although each district has its own
celebrations there is one major festival
celebrated in scp-1505 by the populace
as a whole the parade of candles or
chris mata held once a year on a day
roughly analogous to mid-winter in the
northern hemisphere of the orchard
universe's earth a description of this
festival by junior researcher ramirez
can be found below
the festival's proceedings begin at what
would be 6 a.m in the orchard universe's
kiev the system of time keeping agreed
upon since
scp-5005's foundation residents from all
the districts gather in the central
square to engage in a series of
acrobatic performances poetry readings
artistic displays and musical recitals
the artistic segments of the community
essentially use this event to promote
and discuss their various works while
the rest of the populace treats them as
a form of entertainment it is notable
that while many of these works use the
surrounding dark as their subject matter
it is rare to hear discussion of the
darkness both during festivals and
outside it this activity continues for
several hours while the owners of the
local taverns begin the task
traditionally incumbent on them
constructing a large pyre in the center
of the square the resulting structure is
enormous but due to the prevalence of
fog and snow in scp-505 it is frequently
unusable as a pyre in these cases the
populace simply links arms and dances
around the structure before returning to
their various homes and cooking and
evening feast
if the pyre does catch light however
then tables will be set up surrounding
the fire and the shared feast will take
place in the square the food here is a
mixture of plants grown in the expanse
substance as well as imported food which
makes up the vast majority of the food
consumed in a cp5005 a great many kaivan
and strathclyde delicacies can be found
from the orchard universe as well as
malted saloons from the salom universe a
delicacy brought by the tribal refugees
that has proved surprisingly popular in
the town
after the meal
candles are brought out for the populace
to light from the pyre it will usually
be burning much lower at this stage and
is ordinarily safe to approach having
lit their candles the populace begins to
wander individually and haphazardly
towards the edges of
scp-5051's light range they will spread
themselves out at a safe distance behind
the edge of the circle and holding their
candles aloft begin to sing several
hymns in succession the year's hymns are
voted on during a town meeting they are
primarily from the orchard universe but
some soul and salom songs are sung there
is also usually a reconstructed strisken
song added as part of the continuing
superstition that sriskins created
scp-58051
the singing is not impressive as one
would expect from hundreds of people
spread across a very large distance and
with little training other observers
have called the effect charming it seems
to me to be reflective of the almost
monomaniac obsession that the denizens
have with the light and the fire motif
present in so many artistic works and
important to their conversation and
culture it is a bizarre and disturbing
fact that so many travel to understand
or be inspired by
scp-505's non-material location but end
up ardently embracing the familiar
trappings of home
number three culture by pierre
rachmaninoff reader in literary history
at the university of old kiev
scp-5005's place in the canon of
multiversal literature art and music is
regarded as highly significant its
importance to the orchard universe's
cyberpunk revival is well documented as
is that movement's impact on the culture
of multiple universal clusters perhaps
less known is the sheer scale of
artistic figures who have lived in or
been inspired by scp-5805
the drago man firefall and old shriska
taverns have all seen the formation of a
number of significant literary circles
the renowned 22nd century poet fernand
borgs was deeply affected by scp-505
writing his famous poem the hearth of
baudelaider a ulysses-like attempt to
portray the common life of the city's
inhabitants as a large-scale epic martha
vintage's historical novels all
concerned with sriskin and harkerian
families settling on the edges of space
are thought to have been inspired by her
stay at the firefall but the most famous
literary resident is still de la croix
whose influence over the writing of the
whole of the western universal sectors
is
incalculable the unique moonlight effect
of scp-5051
and the sense of community in the
settlement have been portrayed numerous
times in the visual arts the
franco-solomon painters claude karakoram
mohamed watto and francisco de shiraz
were all drawn to
scp-5005 with karakoram's piece de la
croix bedchamber being the most famous
artworks of the western sector the
musical influence is less easy to trace
but a great many noted composers have
made visits marius konigsberg's
chrismata symphony and the chiron frost
heptet were both composed during his
stay in scp-5005
it is notable that the pieces of
temporary visitors or recent immigrants
to scp-505
are almost invariably focused on the
non-matters surrounding the settlement
while those of long-term residents are
often fixated with the community light
and sensual pleasures various
explanations have been given for this
disparity in subject matter many
short-term residents state that they
came to scp-505
expressly to see the non-matter and that
anything else is simply a distraction
deterring from a proper exploration of
the location's mystery longer-term
inhabitants often talk about the
pointlessness of examining the
non-matter or believe scp-505's purpose
is to act as a beacon against
non-existence the unexplained weather
conditions and the settlement are never
mentioned with a single exception
discussed in dr franklin's essay below
the following is an interview between
researcher ramirez and the famed saul
universe poet juan lumiere who settled
permanently in the town in 2276.
it is included here to give a sense of
the perspective of many longer-term
inhabitants of scp-5005
interviewer junior researcher sophia
ramirez location outside the firefall
tavern date 1212 2524
begin lock junior researcher ramirez is
walking towards the back entrance of the
firefort tavern which opens onto a white
cold street on a slight incline fog can
be seen all around obscuring the rest of
the street the sounds of revelry coming
from inside the firefall can be heard a
man in his thirties wearing a long thick
great coat is smoking a cigarillo
outside the entrance ramirez approaches
him
hello
juan lumiere
the very same you're that foundation
girl
aren't you
staying at the dragoman
junior researcher sophia ramirez
a lovely name
i can only presume given that recording
device on your shoulder that you'll come
to interview me
if we could step inside i prefer to
stand down here
they are bright and merry in there
i'll wait until the fire is lower and
the company more selective
let the young have their fun how old are
you
278
but don't look it do i
the perks of this city i've aged six
years in the time i've been here by my
county
but nobody ever comes here for eternal
life
i've been wondering about that
it's because it doesn't feel like it's
meant to
you don't feel like you're living longer
just that those years have been spread
out longer like skin stretched over a
drum you never develop properly
your writing has
i didn't think anyone in saul had ever
heard of me
it
well if i'm honest it was your work that
first drew me here
you're unusual
your later stuff talks about fire and
light but with much more craft than most
of the other long-termers
you were like the newer ones then i
i do quite like them
but you're like the earlier ones more
everyone likes the earlier ones more
they just don't understand why someone
would come to lamplight just to write
about the things in their own lives to
them in their private salons this place
is just the wild frontier
the mystery beyond mysteries the edge of
all creation they want something wild
not something homespun
isn't that natural
do you write at all
compose
i
i play a little violin
i write some of the stuff in my spare
time but that's not why you came here
you came here to solve its mysteries
it has so many
you're barking up the wrong tree girl
you won't solve anything
you should go inside i'm fine i'm not
here to party and there's your mistake
[Applause]
i've seen so many like you come through
here
you've read de la croix i recently
acquired a copy i haven't read much yet
though
it's his last poem that if not
understood then at least got some
glimpse of this place
rough
almost like a regression into juvenile
but the only thing he wrote that really
threw a light on the bright young things
that come here
full of opium and dreams you think
people come here to see the dark
they come here because they think they
should
they think inspiration is full of the
external depths of the human soul
the ravaged passions of its age
it's not
inspiration is the dust on a wanescott
and the
there's an infinite dark outside a light
that should not exist above why should i
come here to play the fool
this town should not exist it was always
going to exist
this place was inevitable
what does that mean
why did you not help castellano
you drink
the same as me and the rest
what you drink ice cold gin in the
silence of your room
you spend hour after hour puzzling
typing working through things
i see you in your window staring out at
the night and you watched as cascamano
just marched himself off into the night
because you felt the same things he felt
why do you because i've seen you before
a thousand times
the artist falling on his paintbrush as
a sword
the writer who sees god in a grain of
darkness
sometimes i stop them but mostly they
ignore me
the wisdom of youth and all that
one day they'll walk into the night
into the echo chamber of compounded
mystery
never understanding that we built this
place to be a beacon against it
the inevitable human sign of defiance in
the night
hey where are you going i'm not done
with you yet go to the fires junior
researchers of your ramirez
get a shorter name because you'll learn
one way or the other that there is
nothing out there
lumiere walks down the street and into
the fog whistling the blue danube waltz
ramirez stares after him for several
seconds before turning her camera off
end log
number four psychological impact by dr
hans freeburg level three foundation
psychologist
the emotional and psychological effect
scp-5005 has on a large proportion of
its residents is particularly noteworthy
a minimum of 14 disappearances have been
recorded in the town in any given year
extensive investigations by law
enforcement and foundation researchers
have determined these to be almost
entirely suicides
the reasons for this disappearance rate
in a town of scp-5005 size with its
generally high standards of living are
not wholly clear the psychological
effects of a lack of sunlight or a
relatively unvaried diet have been
considered as has the sheer danger of an
unpredictable light source but the most
interesting evidence is that the
overwhelming majority of the
disappearances come from artists writers
and particularly academics who have been
resident in the town for less than a
year these residents often display
similar patterns of behavior in the
weeks prior to their disappearance an
obsession with the non-matter
surrounding the town and increasing
dependence on narcotics and a greatly
increased output but diminished quality
of work many townspeople attempt to
intervene but to little avail affected
individuals are likely to become
increasingly isolated and aggressive
towards others
four foundation personnel are known to
have disappeared in scp-1505 since the
sarai treaty was signed all apparently
committing suicide via non-matter
although a cause of concern for
foundation personnel the unavoidably
limited nature of mental health
provision within the foundation has
meant that this situation is difficult
to overcome
for an example of some of the concerns
typically raised with the foundation's
psychiatric unit the following is an
extract from director franklin's report
of a check-in with junior researcher
ramirez on december 25 24.
after the meal dr ramirez took me to her
rooms to show me some of her initial
findings by this point i noticed several
things that concerned me having known dr
ramirez for several years her voice
seemed markedly more strained than usual
she also seemed nervous and she was
sweating profusely several times i
thought i smelled alcohol on her breath
her rooms turned out to be a single
cheap bed chamber on the tavern's top
floor there was little heating and no
light the window opening out of the
johto district i asked her why she had
chosen this room when we had allotted
her a generous allowance she replied
that the rooms on the lower floors were
too noisy and that she needed quiet to
work i thought this plausible at the
time
cp5005's taverns are not known for being
serene places of study
but on further reflection i remembered
that two previous researchers kobold and
mcbride had similarly changed their
accommodation both had to be pulled out
of scp-5005 and both had developed the
notion that a higher room would take
them closer to the source of the town's
non-mata a curious piece of unscientific
superstition
i also noticed that although the bed
chamber appeared to be in an orderly
condition there was a sheen of dust
across many of the surfaces and a couple
of telltale signs were visible that
indicated a lot of tidying in a very
short amount of time
the bed did not look like it had been
slept in several fiction books also
coated in dust were lying on the shelves
only the poetry of delacroix and two of
lumiere's novels seemed to have been
read at all there was a half-empty
bottle of gin on the mantelpiece which
ramirez quickly noticed and binned in a
half-hearted attempt at subterfuge
her notes written by hand were
surprisingly rough she seemed to only
use her digital for forwarding her data
to us the haphazard organization went
some way towards explaining the
decreased quality of her work but the
odd breaks in writing tone and lack of
professionalism and interviews still had
to be answered for by this point i
regretted letting other projects take my
attention away from scp-505
i sent sophia here because of her
well-demonstrated resilience and
reliability thinking i could leave the
town's research in safe hands
however it has become abundantly clear
that the effects this place has on the
human psyche
are not so easily predictable
i asked a few gentle questions about her
life here had she been blending in was
she enjoying the local culture and it
did not take long for her to become
paranoid and resentful of my presence
she openly mocked the town's people for
being rural
believing their cultural traditions and
community were worthless in the context
of their surroundings she lamented their
lack of curiosity in scp-505-1
the expanse and the surrounding non-mata
to my surprise she also displayed little
interest in lumiere's writings something
which had previously been a passion of
hers and actively disdained delacroix
calling his last poem irredeemable [ __ ]
that understands nothing
the true nature of her interests rapidly
became apparent she had devised a schema
based on the angles of scp-50
light to find a location where the
bizarre laws of physics would allow
someone to see the entirety of the
expanse which scp-5005 rests upon she
had done an extraordinary amount of
research pinpointing this supposed
location to the exact spot and designing
a craft she believed would safely
transport people to and from this place
it was madness and i told her as much
this location was so far out that no
craft however well designed could keep
its occupants alive for the return
journey
she did not want to hear this and it
became clear that she did not desire my
presence
any longer
i did not tell her about my intention to
recall her fearing this might damage her
emotional state still further
still it is my unambiguous
recommendation that she be replaced in
her post as soon as possible
scp-5005 may not have a great deal of
exploitable material within it but we
still don't fully understand the town
its mysteries its
strange law for artists and writers or
the nuances of the local culture
it's not an easy assignment and it needs
a great deal more attention than we have
hitherto given it
number five future research by director
hamish franklin
the result of these many aspects of
scp-1505
is that the foundation has a number of
potential research directions while the
cultural and social aspects of the town
remain important and their relation to
the landscape in particular remains an
unresearched area it is the physical
questions that are the most potent the
identity of
scp-5051's creators and their reasons
for doing so its mechanical workings and
the nature of the expanse surrounding
the town
one final notable anomaly is the unusual
weather conditions of the town as the
orchard universe lacks heavy snow and
fog this has often been considered one
of the key attractions for the initial
settlers its origin and source are
entirely unknown however and very few
credible theories have been produced to
explain it originating at a point
somewhere above scp-5051
the snow falls regularly enough to keep
the town covered in a thin layer at all
times the source of the fog is also
unclear but in both cases the weather
conditions appear identical to those
found in soul and similar universes
a related problem is near complete
absence of these conditions in any
literary or artistic works researchers
have noted that the townspeople rarely
discuss it often appearing dismissive
and frightened when it is brought up
researchers themselves have openly
stated after leaving the town that the
weather made them feel uncertain or lost
extensive testing has ruled out the
possibility of any memetic or cognito
hazardous effects
as mentioned above the only known
creative work to discuss these
conditions is the final poem of
scp-5005's founder john antoine
delacroix it is written in a much more
modernist style than delacroix's other
works and does not display the same
technical mastery this may be partly
attributed to its status as an
unfinished work found written on his
desk the morning after his disappearance
it is reproduced in its entirety below
cold entrance cuts the mountain
where i buried you salt and brine
whisper down the waterways of ash
where you ran
laughing
that mouth-made twist turned bitter
here
on the edge of human eyes i stare into
the mirror of the dark
that mirror that sees my ravages of bone
and brings such images of the world's
dismay
its broken luminous char
its dreams of all the starving artists
beavering away an opium or simmering
soft in pain
casting off the trappings of the world
which leaves just silence
soft and cold disdain
the hearths and songs that bleed with
frail light have drawn to fires those
who huddle tight
their raptured peasant fear
cast before the tongues in cheer
i walk
a figure in the fog of old laments
away from these twin tails and into the
snow
into the earth
with no narratives of foes
or platitudes of friends
the snow gives rod
complexity
on we
the night
does not give such easy answers
addendum 1
on 31 12 25 24 junior researcher ramirez
disappeared from her lodgings in the
drago man tavern a search by townspeople
and foundation personnel found only
footprints in the snow heading towards
the edge of town on the evening of o101
2525 a signal was received from a
temporary monitoring station set up on a
cp5005 it appeared to show video footage
from junior researcher ramirez's
shoulder cam had a point in the
non-matter analysis of the footage
showed that it had been transmitted
several hours earlier from the location
specified in her conversation with
director franklin although it is
theoretically possible for her to have
made this trip unaided she would have
been close to death by the time she
reached the location as her apparent
condition in the footage makes clear
a log of this footage is below
camera opens on non-matter this is
rendered as a black screen coughing can
be heard
it told you
hamish
i told you
you stood there
and you were wrong and i was right and
there is heavy breathing for several
seconds
but you
but you won't guess you'll never
guess
the camera turns in the distance
scp-5005 can be seen beneath scp-505
the light of
scp-5051 refracts across the non-mata in
a way which shows the entirety of the
expanse
the expanse is revealed as the corpse of
an augmented harcretian anglerfish most
of the body has been eroded by non-mata
but the face and jaw are clearly visible
scp-5051 can be clearly seen as the esca
of the fish the lore anglerfish possess
to attract prey to them its eyes
possessing a milky white collar typical
of anglerfish are also visible
ramirez can be heard laughing
hysterically for approximately 30
seconds this is then interrupted by
coughing blood can be seen floating in
front of the camera
that's it isn't it
isn't it
the end of the line
the puzzle box complete just the dying
corpse of harkert's pioneers
there is a pause after which sobbing can
be heard
i wonder if they
died
there or
or ran away or
found something better out here i
i wonder if further sobbing can be heard
for 12 minutes before fading away
entirely fog and snow can be seen
approaching from the sides of the camera
gradually obscuring its field of view
until nothing visible remains the visual
feed cuts out
the knight does not give such easy
answers
the audio feed cuts out
i would like to give a special thank you
to
j alsop
zargaran
professor puffer
the morrigan
retalias
karim el ashmuy
amir saban
seventy
blitzkrieg
kristoff kozak slesak
hms lily
the almighty fish
gav the clumsy containment specialist
spooky aqua
pure osmium
sciodio damnatis
brian sanchez
matthew gilmore
drew peacock
eric corbage
longinus
king madding
james saba
and
njvojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the vulgar
thank you
you